politique à présent avec la clôture ce
week-end de l'université de la rentrée
du modem à la tribune le patron du parti
centriste françois bayrou a réitéré son
soutien indéfectible à alain juppé
fidèle à sa ligne il n'a pas ménagé les
critiques à l'encontre de nicolas
sarkozy sont jamais cités karens et var
et thierry meyer
la salle elle n'est pas très grande mais
pleines à craquer c'est la cinquième
fois que le modem organise ici à guidel
est son université de rentrée pour
françois bayrou la bretagne est une
terre centriste dont il soutient la
profonde identité régionale une occasion
de tacler au passage le discours de
nicolas sarkozy
mais l'obsession de l'identité devient
un handicap est une menace pour ceux qui
s'y livrent et c'est aussi une ruse
pendant qu'on renvoie les français aux
gaulois et les gabonais au gabon
on ne parle pas des vrais sujets en
détournant l'attention de citoyens de la
vraie vie en réalité on les abusent et
on les trompes c'est une autre forme
d'opium des peuples mauvais temps apaisé
et unir sont les maîtres mots du
discours de françois bayrou qui justifie
ainsi son soutien à alain juppé je suis
heureux
qu'alain juppé ait montré qu'il était un
homme de volonté qu'il était un homme de
parole qu'il était solide et responsable
et qu'il est et ce faisant un homme
d'honneur aujourd'hui françois bayrou
apporte sa confiance à la jupe et moi
j'ai confiance en françois bayrou ils
sont extrêmement complémentaires tous
les deux et ils ont mais la même vision
de la france tous les deux donc
ça rassure une grande majorité de deux
français si c'est nicolas sarkozy qui
arrive en tête françois bayrou sera bel
et bien candidat
et pour parler de l'actualité du
mouvement démocrate nous retrouvons yann
wehrling porte parole ellis président du
modem on vient de le voir donc si
nicolas sarkozy remporté la primaire
françois bayrou partira au combat il
accuse l'ancien président dit ce père
yves et le débat oui vous le constatez
comme comme moi comme tout le monde
depuis quelques semaines depuis que
nicolas sarkozy est entré en campagne
les thèmes qui a choisi de mettre en
avant sans des thèmes au fond ne sont
pas les thèmes prioritaires pour les
français les français eux se préoccupent
de leurs fins de mois mais nicolas
sarkozy a décidé une fois de plus comme
il l'avait créée par le passé de mettre
en avant des thèmes qui antagonisent les
français certains français contre
d'autres ils pensent que c'est en
attisant on va dire des feux qui peut
être été éteints pour que c'est comme ça
qu'il va pouvoir gagner des points et
nous nous ne partageons évidemment pas
cette manière de voir les choses alors
il soutient on vient de voir également
de manière indéfectible alain juppé est
ce que les militants du modem ce qu'ils
sont prêts à suivre la ligne indiqué par
monsieur bayrou écoutez je crois que les
militants du modem comme les français
comme beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs qui
peuvent d'ailleurs ne pas forcément ceux
situés à droite ou au centre sont
aujourd'hui à se poser des questions
qu'est ce qui va se passer demain qu'est
ce qui va se passer au second tour de la
présidentielle et je crois que tout le
monde est concerné en réalité sur le
choix qui sera à faire à cette occasion
et donc la primaire c'est le moment de
choisir le président de la république
que nous voulons en réalité est bien
évidemment pour nous si c'est alain
juppé le centre que nous représenterait
que nous représentons sera incarné par
ce candidat quelle sera l un juppé c'est
la raison pour laquelle on le soutient
alors tout est possible pour 2017 petit
rappel en 2012 françois bayrou assembler
un tout petit peu plus de 9% des
suffrages au premier tour et un sondage
a été publié aujourd'hui et il pourrait
peut-être calmer un petit peu les
ardeurs et les ambitions de monsieur
bayrou regarder
45% des personnes interrogées disent
avoir une bonne opinion de monsieur
bayrou ce qui est quand même une
performance un vu le contexte national
en revanche un bémol de taille 70 % ne
pense pas qu'il ferait un bon président
qu'est ce qu'il manque à françois bayrou
si vous me permettez une autre lecture
de ce sont des désirs % des français
pendant qu'il ferait un bon président de
la république s'il est vivant j'aimerais
savoir combien ferai d'autres potentiels
présidentiables aujourd'hui à l'élection
donc là on a 30 % est ce que nicolas
sarkozy est ce que françois hollande par
exemple et voir emmanuel macron frais 30
% de bonnes opinions pour devenir un
président de la république voilà c'est
des questions que je pose est une
manière de présenter les choses qui sont
plus ou moins on va dire aux nets
pourraient ainsi à des lectures
effectivement possible vous évoquiez à
l'instant à monsieur macro emmanuel
macron est-ce que c'est finalement pas
lui
l'adversaire le plus solide face à
monsieur bayrou si demain il se présente
écoutez moi c'est très simple je juge
les gens à ce qu'ils ont fait emmanuel
macron télé premier jour de l'élection
de françois hollande était à ses côtés
pour conduire la politique économique
qui a été menée dans ce pays et qui est
là où nous en sommes aujourd'hui avec un
taux de pauvreté extraordinaire le choc
fiscal il était là quand il a été décidé
et puis vous savez moi j'étais un ancien
responsable des écologistes en france
inc les pognes qui pourrait
potentiellement
causé la mort de dfc nîmes emmanuel
macron qui l'a décidé alstom aujourd'hui
qui est en difficulté parce qu'il ya
plus de train parce que les trains sont
désertés par les autocars qui a fait une
loi qui favorise les autocars et qui
vide les trains c'est emmanuel macron
jeu juste sur les faits moi c'est fait
aujourd'hui demande m'invite pas à
trouver que emmanuel macron incarne
quelque chose d'intéressant pour le pays
en tout cas pas une vision ultralibérale
telle qu'il incarne qui n'est pas du
tout notre option en tout cas pas un
partenaire on l'a compris de monsieur
bayrou dans un éventuel gouvernement
d'union nationale merci infiniment
monsieur d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce soir